It was like any other peaceful
afternoon in my home in 2004.
Cartoons were blaring,
kids were running
around the house, yelling loudly,
"VeggieTales" on 100.
Well, maybe not so peaceful,
but for a young mother, it was perfect.
It was like music to my ears.
But then there was a loud
knock at the door
that just disrupted that laughter.
And my kids yelled out to me, “Mommy,
The police are at the door!”
And as I walked up to talk to the police,
it's almost like I walked
into the Charlie Brown movie.
Do you all remember the teacher
when she just like, “Womp, womp, womp?”
Because the words were just getting lost,
and I didn’t know what was going on.
And I just snapped out of it
and I was like,
"Oh, shit.
I'm about to be arrested."
I was about to be arrested
because two months prior
I had wrote a check
for $87.26 for groceries.
And that check had bounced.
And let me be clear.
There is a thing called
prosecutorial discretion,
meaning the district attorney
did not have to prosecute me,
but they did.
And totally against
my fashion statement, right,
the police placed
these silver bracelets on my arms.
Handcuffs.
And that day they handcuffed me
in front of my babies.
And took me to jail.
You know, luckily I was able
to come home pretty quickly
because it was my first offense.
And I promise, the first thing
I did when I got home,
I borrowed some money
so I could pay that check back.
And then I had to borrow some more money
to pay back the fees
for getting arrested and going to jail
because, of course, I was loaded in cash
because I was a young mom with four kids
bouncing 87-dollar checks.
And I just knew that that chapter
of my life was closed.
Except it wasn't, because see,
that arrest in that conviction,
it remained on my record.
And at that moment,
I realized that my true
sentence had just begun,
because you know what?
I was no longer allowed to volunteer
at my children’s school.
I could no longer rent
where I want to rent
because it is legal
for landlords to discriminate
against a person with a record.
I even faced barriers
trying to go to college.
And still to this day I am excluded
from certain certifications
and occupational license.
All I could keep asking myself was, "Damn,
when will my sentence end?”
And sadly, I am not alone.
There are more than 100 million Americans,
that is one in three people,
who have an arrest
or conviction on their record.
And get this, more
than 94 percent of employers,
more than 90 percent of landlords
and 72 percent of colleges
and universities
use background checks
to screen out applicants,
making it harder for millions
of Americans to access jobs,
housing and education.
It's like, damn, how am I supposed
to get out and do better
if no one will rent to me,
no one will hire me,
and I can’t even go to school?
But I believe, I truly believe
that America is a nation
of second chances.
And I say that
because just about every state
has laws on the books
that allow a person
to get their record cleared
once they're eligible.
And right now, there are more
than 30 million people
who are eligible
to get their record cleared.
But this is where it gets a little crazy.
Less than 10 percent of those people
actually get it done.
Either they don’t know about it,
or, if they do, the process
is so bureaucratic,
costly and full of red tape.
For instance, in some states people have
to wait just about five to 10 years
just to even qualify
to get their record cleared.
Then you have to appear
in person to petition.
That means you need to take time off work,
and let's keep it real,
it was hard enough
to find a job in the first place.
You have to file a mountain of paperwork
and then sometimes
you have to pay processing fees
up to 500 dollars per charge.
And then if you're smart,
you may want to just get a lawyer
to help you navigate that whole process.
So that means if your crime
was being poor like mine,
record clearance is not even accessible.
I'm looking at some of your faces.
You seem really bummed out
and discouraged.
But I promise I didn't come all the way
to Vancouver, TED, to tell you bad news.
(Laughter)
I got some good news.
(Applause)
This record clearance problem
is solvable and it's fixable
and we're doing the damn thing.
And the key is automatic record clearance
for those who are eligible.
We are removing all that red tape,
and we do that by passing
what we call “clean slate” laws.
And what that is, is laws that say
once a person has remained crime-free
for a set period of time
and they're eligible,
a set period of time by the state’s
definition, remaining crime-free,
that their record
is automatically cleared.
Red tape cut.
And this is the beautiful thing about it.
We shift the burden from the person
who made the mistake
to the system that tries
to trap them in that mistake.
(Applause)
And y'all, these policies are working.
And I know that
because I am the proud CEO
of the Clean Slate Initiative.
And in just the last three years,
we've been able to help six states
pass clean slate laws.
I'm talking about red states, blue states
and even purple states, OK?
(Applause)
That has resulted in three million people
getting their records cleared.
That's millions of people who no longer
have to walk around with stigma
and shame attached to their name.
I even, one time y'all,
met this older fellow.
I mean, he was in his 80s,
but he was a fragile 80-year-old man.
I met him in Miami, Florida,
at an expungement clinic,
and I could not fathom
why this man was there.
He was there to get his record cleared.
And all I could think about was,
he wasn't there to get a job,
find housing.
He didn't want to die
being defined by his record.
Clean slate laws will even help
people like him too.
It's like with a stroke
of a governor's pen,
we were able to unlock
dreams for millions.
And because it’s an Audacious Project,
we're on a pathway to make automatic
record clearance a reality.
A reality in all 50 states.
We're building a pathway
that automatic record clearance
is a reality in all 50 states
that will unlock second chances
for additional 14 million people.
(Cheers and applause)
I just want to leave you all with this.
And I even invite some of you
to close your eyes when I ask you this.
Because it's really important.
I want you to think about all
the second chances that you've received.
Whether it was from your teachers,
your parents,
your community,
even your kids.
Think about what that felt like.
Think about what that did for you.
I know for me,
it enabled me to be able to change,
like turn my pain into purpose.
It enabled me to be able
to walk into a room and feel seen,
not as damaged goods,
but as untapped potential.
(Applause)
That is the power of a second chance.
That is the power of a clean slate.
And there's no greater gift than that.
Thank you.
(Cheers and applause)